et bien voilà nous besoin sont par
nature on a une liste qui porte très
fortement la volonté de transformer la
ville de besançon transformer c'est
rendre active une ville qui n'était pas
encore incapable d'être allé sur les
métiers d'avenir sur l'urbanisme
d'avenir sur des problématiques de
biodiversité la question du climat est
aujourd'hui l'écologie elle s'est
consolidée parce qu'elle s'est appuyée
sur un rassemblement rassemblement de
merci de m'envoyer au merci beaucoup
eric alauzet 30 secondes pour vous aussi
finalement c'est mon métier de médecin
qui illustre à la fois ce que je suis et
ce que je veux pour cette ville de
besançon un médecin humaniste pour une
ville fraternelle un médecin praticien à
la recherche des choses concrètes
pratiques pas des discours des choses
qui marchent les besoins de répondre à
mes patients immédiatement pas de leur
promettre un médicament dans dix ans un
médecin écologistes parce que je me suis
intéressé très tôt impact delà de la
société sur notre santé un médecin
entrepreneurs parce que médecin libéral
est aussi entrepreneur parce que à des
précurseurs de l'écologie sur besançon
il a 30 ans à une époque où c'était pas
facile et je termine en disant pluie
c'est fini désolé on dirait ce que
j'avais voilà tant pis tant pis voila
voila merci beaucoup mais alexandra
cordier c'est à vous je jeu monsieur
lozès qu'à un moment donné vous
intéresser aux bisons parlez vous parlez
de votre conclusion s'il vous plaît ce
qui m'intéresse moi ce sont les bisons
temps avec les listes ensemble notre
projet on a conçu notre projet et notre
liste avec les bisontins et pour eux
donc je pense qu un maire doit être
rassembleur mais doit être la mère en
tout cas où le maire de tous les
bisontins et moi je m'engage à être le
porte-parole des bisontins et à faire en
sorte qu'il faut mieux représentés
claire arnaud vos trente secondes
très bien donc en fait on en a très peu
parlé mais on va arriver dans une
période qui va être critique pour
l'humanité en général à besançon en
particulier avec des pics de canicule
qui on est plus important et donc la
transition écologique est une nécessité
et nous on lit ça à l'écologie populaire
à la solidarité parce qu'on a besoin que
tout le monde se mette à ce travail là
et donc on peut pas avoir un tel taux de
pauvreté à besançon qu'un sujet le
social cas pas du toit était abordé et
on glisse a aussi
l'implication citoyenne parce que de
nouveaux une ville en transition c'est
une ville qui doit impliquer tout le
monde nous le fait qu'on veut renouveler
la démocratie avec le référendum
d'initiative suel le référendum accord c
est bon et merci tout plein ludovic
fagots vous savez tous les représentants
qui sont ici autour de la table sont
issus de la majorité sortante mais moi
je ne fais pas partie de leur cerveau et
je ne fais pas partie de la pub il avait
le pouvoir de changer les choses mais
ils ne l'ont pas fait qu'ils ont échoué
et en plus ils sont des fausses et
besançon a rendez vous aujourd'hui avec
l'avenir je ne serai pas le maire d'un
clan je serais vraiment le maire des
bisontines et des bisontins parce que
nous avons des talents des talents à
faire valoir et je souhaite vraiment que
besançon soit enfin la ville de tous les
possibles et les bisontins et les
bisontines attendent ce changement et je
remettrai vraiment en oeuvre est de la
ville dans la ville avec l'ensemble de
mon équipe
jacques rétiaire des ti beccu témoignera
pas de concept fumeux pour nous c'est la
sécurité avec du concret 20 millions
d'euros l'armure de la police municipale
enfin tout ce qu'on a pu développer
jusqu'à maintenant de la proximité donc
au plus près des préoccupations des
bisontins c'est c'est un conseil
municipal délocaliser dans chacun des
quartiers une fois par an du concret
toujours et du localisme et bien
évidemment du localisme dans
l'alimentation est bien évidemment
redonner des places de crèches de 2 dans
les cantines à aux élèves bisontin parce
que même ça on n'en a pas parlé voyez
c'est quand même étonnant donc pour nous
du concret